i've talked about this before but i
think it bears repeating
you've probably noticed a lot of
late-night hosts out there they just
come out and they tell some monologue
jokes all right
that's fine for them but this guy
i like to innovate okay i'm sorry other
hosts
that's just the way i roll you see i
found a way
to tell great topical jokes here at the
top of the show
that add excitement sex appeal and
a little 80s nostalgia it's a great new
way i've devised
we're going to do it again tonight check
it out
well it was reported today that there
are 240 u.s schools named for
confederate leaders
yeah the uh confederate leaders include
robert e lee
stonewall jackson and kid rock
breaking news we have world peace now
thanks to conan's epic burn
did you ever think that you could laugh
while you
learn
what what was that what do you mean what
was that
i'm trying to save the world with
laughter andy
oh hey fox news is
laying off the people who do hair and
makeup or as fox news calls them
reporters conan's words just caused the
truth quake
trust the bad guys in a blink he has
jokes that make you smile and men
and you think
i yeah i don't know how that made me
think yeah okay andy
just go with it all right go with it
it's working
all right recent polls reveal that joe
biden is struggling with latino voters
today biden reminded a latino group that
he voted against the mexican-american
war
sleepy joe just got destroyed now direct
hit from cob
he's crying on an amtrak train the power
of
comedy
you know this is actually my least
favorite song
written for the movie st almost fire
thanks andy i'll keep that noted okay
one more scientists have discovered a
noxious gas on venus
that's a sign of life of course here on
earth a noxious gas is a sign
of a nearby arby's oh you've got
punchline fever
temperature of 103. comet is the
antidote and cone is the vaccine
well looks like no snarky comment from
andy on that one
and he doesn't like this song but no one
asks what andy likes
cut to him right now look he's not
paying attention